hunt for the wilderbeest from the
director who brought us what we do in
the shadows boy and Eagle versus shark
this film star sam neill who finds
himself in the middle of a difficult
predicament when this kid that his wife
adopted suddenly doesn't have anyone to
take care of him they live on a farm in
the middle of New Zealand and this kid
decides he wants to go on a hike in the
woods one day and gets lost
sam neill goes out there and because of
a series of mishaps that i don't want to
spoil for you they decide to stay in the
woods while a national manhunt is going
on to find both of them similar to this
filmmakers other films this is a very
quirky comedy it's offbeat it's very
heartfelt it's very endearing and all of
these things shine extremely true in
this movie sam neill gives the best
performance i think i've seen from him
since jurassic park he's amazing in this
film as this really hardened grizzled
older guy who's just dealt with so much
crap in his life and now he's sitting
here looking at this kid who couldn't be
any more different from him trying to
figure out how they're going to navigate
these woods together while also not
going insane because they're just so
different and this kid Ricky was raised
on hiphop
juvenile detention he's a foster kid he
has a really rough past he doesn't
really know who his parents are but he
loves reading he loves writing he loves
creating music and so the two of them
have a very strange relationship that
develops and this film quickly became
one of the best comedies I've seen so
far this year due to how well it's
directed how well it's written and just
how offbeat all the performances are
it's sort of like if Jared Hess who made
Napoleon Dynamite nacho libre it's like
if he made a great movie but it's so
well thought out and so well performed
and the editing is just pitch perfect
there's also a great soundtrack this
movie really surprised me I couldn't
believe how much fun I was having with
hunt for the wilderness to to those
excellent performances and the chemistry
between Sam Neill and this kid and as
the film progressed I just became so
attached to these characters it's tough
to relate this film to anything in
recent memory there's also a lot of
really good supporting characters as
well like this woman from Child Services
and her
policeman partner they're sort of like
Andy Griffith and Don Knotts from The
Andy Griffith Show they're just they're
bickering constantly but she wants so
much to find this kid because you can
tell she just gets so into it she's so
into this manhunt she's so excited about
it and it's it's like taking over a life
and the humor that's played through that
is excellent guys this was an
exceptionally charming movie with such
great characters with such good
performances so endearing and heartfelt
and not sappy at all I felt so invested
in these guys and I was so into their
adventure the only issues I had with
this movie were towards the end
no spoilers one character in particular
makes a choice and says some things that
just felt totally out of character and
for me it was sort of like they were
just trying to get more drama out of
that situation but it was very forced
and it didn't feel like something the
character would actually do the pacing
is also a little slow sometimes
besides that hunt for the will deliver
'it comedies of the year and i'm gonna
give it an a - guys thank you so much as
always for watching when this movie
comes out i highly suggest checking it
out when different movies like this open
i really think we should support them
thanks once again guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes